Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to West of loathing now
You may be thinking that everything is hunky-dory and exactly the same as it was and you'd be
Partially correct except that I'm a snake oiler now hell
Yeah, I got the shootie snakes
And I got a snake whip and I've got deploy snake and I've got the greatest ability ever called Shootenanny
It's all pretty good
But I'm in the exact same place that I was before in addition to a few new places that I want to go to
before I actually continue number one I have to go see the crazy old professor the professor's house because I got to turn in my Elvenecio
El Vombo
Elvenoobo EL Vom bunuh, Elva nee Bow elvenebo  something like that elveneebow
LV knee LV knee Bow
Elvano, great. Let me just hmm. Yep, okay?
This will do the trick let me just get this running and then you'll be able to grab a key stone from it
It'll take another five scrap for each one
You need. Are you familiar with the Lost dutch oven mine, grimm place,
But that's where I found the chassis for the fabricator wedged behind an unusual pile of rocks seems like a good place to start hunting
All right, I'm on it. Hiyah! I got a key stone
So this is this is actually referring to another location that I actually discovered
And I didn't want to go to it yet because it sounded hilarious
It's the lost dutch oven mine
And if it's if it's a place of only fart jokes then you know you know that I'm interested in it
but as a as a snake oiler number one, I got a snake whip whapow and
Gary's just as tough as Gary's always been Gary's much better as he was now, but also
I'm real good with the shooting and don't worry
I went through every single Spittoon that I doth did see before so don't worry about any of that
Oh no, such a smell that Gary to smelling. It's really something
Yeah, oof Gary to waiting out here and breathing through mouth. Good call, buddy.
But me, I'll brave the danger. Whoa those are some stinky fissures
I can't get any closer now without some stench resistance at least now see I
I've waded through so many spittoons. I've flushed so many toilets
That I gotta have some sweet-smelling flowers to be able to conquer this horrible mine the stench here is barely tolerable
mmm
So funny. Doodly do a doodlay do ah
Loot them, got miners pants and a gas mask. Well I guess that'd probably help
Gas mask, huh, I've already got stench resistance, so I guess I'm okay.  Alright miners must have eaten down here
Got clove drops and cat's eye candy. That's good
It's another spittoon
Yes, I don't know what kind of tobacco these miners are chewing
But it must be extra corrosive because the brass spittoon has a hole eaten through the bottom and dark stains underneath the where the  spit leaked out.
Although oddly, it doesn't seem to be leaking now, and it's half-full. I guess the miners plugged the hole with something. Inspect it.
It's a spittoon. It's disgusting you can practically see the stink lines coming off of it.
Come on, let's not do this inspect the spittoon ah geez fine, okay?
You crouch down and take a careful look at the filthy spittoon the inside is blackened with years worth of stains the Dead broth the
death broth inside is a rainbow sheen like a parking lot oil spill and
Occasionally a little bubble pops on the surface you can actually feel a slight warmth radiating off of it from whatever dire
Chemical reaction is taking place in there. You realize you're holding your breath not deliberately from the human body's natural
instinct for self-preservation
My option is inhale.
Imagine someone made a big pot of chili con carne and left it under the porch three rats call it the pot
Eat half the chili, and then die a week later a family of cockroaches
takes up residence among the writhing maggots the cockroaches smoke thick black cigars
Which they light with tufts of burning human hair. That's what it smells like
Search it bad boy
Fortunately for you the rainbow-colored film on the surface of the liquid coats your hand as you plunge into the toxic stew
Keeping it from being immediately dissolved down to the bones
the smell intensifies in your stomach prepares to hose the poisons off
off of your arm with a high pressure stream of vomit
Keep searching your fingers touch something at the bottom of the spittoon. You better pull it out fast while you still have something to pull with
You pull the world's most
Disgusting pair of pants out of the spittoon and jump back as the whole of the spittoons bottom now unplugged begins to Leak
steaming filth
congratulations
You are now the proud owner of the worst object
I've ever been paid to think about narrowly defeating a leather bondage harness made from the skin of a clown
Oh, I gotta find the leather bondage harness. I have to find that now that's so hilarious
Hooray!
I guess oh
Geez that is so funny.
Oh my God that is the best. Oil it?
I have a can of oil? Wait. Do I have a can of oil? Oh
Jeez that's a little better
I didn't know I..
Oh, I have a can I can use that on the gate to not kill those people
I can do that because now I actually have that but I'm gonna use that
Hang on... I didn't kill him this time around. You lubricate the elevator liberally, huh? Oh
Yeah, I do
Get that clown bondage harness and have a good old time. Alright, what do you got?
Nope scadoodling in there. What do we got down at the bottom of this place?
You emerge from the elevator into a deeper shaft by the light of your lantern you see exposed meat veins on nearly every surface, huh?
My dream. It's unusual that there would be this much readily available Meat left in a working mine. What were they digging for, if not this?
Curious...
All right, okay. Meat it up
Meat it up. Meat it-hi..
Hi there buddy, how you doing?
You having a good time there?
All right, just feeling the music this guy's totally out of it. He's gibbering and drooling. It doesn't seem to even see you
Leave him to his gibbering. I'll try talking to him. Hey buddy. Are you okay? Glob rob bibble berto
gordo glub. Uh-huh. You wave your hand in front of his face, but he doesn't react at all. HmM. All right
It's an exposed meat vein
Good
Hello, shovels dulled to uselessness a broken Pickaxe. Was one of the miners digging with his helmet?
Jeesh,  what were they digging so rapidly for?
Looks like the miner died trying to dig deeper with their hands
Ominous ladder leading down into a deep dark pit. All right, okay?
Ooh, well this looks bad. Finger bones are all splintered.  The hairs on the back of your neck stands up
This guy seems to have knawed off his own hands before dying. Your heart is pounding
The gem is pretty but it smells terrible I got an effluvious emerald. Wait, I got to check out my my pants.
I have these moxie pants. I'm gonna put them on.
I've also got these overly tan boots that are just to die for oh, that's good stuff
I don't know a good speed does oh there it is
Both sides have equal speeds whatever sure whatever all right?
This guy worked his fingers to the bone diggin and then worked his bones to the marrow you have to get out of this pit right now
Not yet I don't! These scratches are just painted on in blood you have to pit right now
The Gouge marks are dark with blood you have to get out of this pit right now
No, I don't. As you get near the rocks the voices in your head begin screaming
Too loudly to ignore you, have to get it out of this pit right now. Fine, fine, whatever..
Ugh, fine, whatever rolling away I go like a coward
Why am I getting out of this pit?
What's going on?
Hey, we dude. What's the dealio?
What do I gotta get out of this pit right now? What's going on here?
Wait, there's some going on here, and I ain't too sure about it the dutch oven mine will spill its secrets for me
Whatever wait, let me check out the effluvious diamond. If this gem is half as valuable as it is pungent
You're in the money. You should probably wash your hands before you spend it. All right, okay. Fine then, so is there some reason?
So why did?
Why did the professor send me down here?
That's the weird thing right. Why did the professor send me down here?
Let me go back to the professor's house just to see what's going on over there because...
Oh, trading yes, please Wandering Sally, got any good stuff for me. Eh, some needles
I've got three shovels. I only need one so there we go. Oh the other thing about being a snake oil
I've got a briefcase full of snakes if you look inside, I can squeeze some Venom or some medicine now
I don't know. I don't know how to upgrade my
My snake briefcase you know Snake Falls or Snake Springs is like an unlimited supply of snake
So you just go there, and you fill up your briefcase as much as you want, but yeah
It's whatever. Who's fighting? Who am I fighting? Snakes? Goddamn it. Time to Shootenanny up!
Bang bam boom ban oh, I didn't get all of them. Whatever that just shoots randomly in random locations
Randomly in Random locations. You know how random things are
I'm so random. Coffee cactus. Oh also, I've got safecracking finally which is nice you know anything about Ley Lines? Woah
Ley line diagram you say?
Okay, check out the necromancer journal alright
Well that didn't do anything for me. Well, then why did you send me? Why'd you send me to that God damn mine alright?
I'll come back to that. I got other stuff to do too, but first
I'm gonna go to Ol" Granddad because that's where the quest
The main Quest is sending me and then I got all these other places that I'm gonna go I'm gonna go to Madness Maw Mine
soon
I like the sound of it, even though It's probably terrible and horrifying. Alright. Hey, dude. How's it going? Hey? What's up, man? You wanna?
You want to get a bar of soap?
Thanks, man. Let me up there alright. Hey, dude. How's it going alright? I'll be right back. Hey
Oh, what?
To heck with the tap?
What I don't have enough moxie. Oh, I'm three off. Well is there something I could eat that would give me some moxie
I know there would be I've already put something on my hat so I can't do that
There's got to be something here that'll give me some moxie
Muscle, black and beans, and that's by one
Woo that's good, potted meat sounds good. It's all by five. I'll eat that
You pry up with the can, eat the meat. It tastes way better than you expected it to. Meat it out. Hey, that's pretty good
I'll be darned. I'll be dinged damned darned. All right..ooo. That's some good Moxie.
Oh yeah, this looks like the stuff. All right, I'm gonna drink this. Bloinc. Decent wine, pretty classy, nice, and stuff. Potion
Alright muscle by Eleven, but you shouldn't drink it. Oh you probably shouldn't drink cow's blood. I'm gonna skip on that one
Skip on that old bad boy
Sarsapa
Sas-paperilla
lollia
Sasperilollia
Oh, okay? All right, then I'm gonna drink me some you you were never sure how to spell this and you still aren't
I'm gonna drink me some
Sharperilia, you drink the
substance
Saspa-whatever
oh
It's funny funny stuff funny stuff. All right
I got enough moxie find a tap all right spirit tap syrup tap whatever tap it tap that
All right
It's all tapped out okay. I'm out of goo. You want some goo? There you go
There you go needing more proper? Needing more?. All right? Well there you go. Whatever. It's fine. Jesus. You greedy bastard
All right, hi hello. Hi can I nope?
Okay, can I- yep bringing me Goblin elixir? What's that a potion of extra delicious. So good! Okay?
I'll go get that then fine geez whatever oh, well. What's this?
This table is covered with flasks, beakers, bottles, and tubes and burners and all the other equipment that makes up a super elaborate alchemy table
Including a whole bunch of different colored liquids and powders and such. Make a goblin elixir. That's easy for you to say..
Look for some instructions
I just try mixing things you pick up a beater and look at the ingredient ha ha green powder is probably good
How about some clear juice that sounds good it turns brown. Pink syrup?
It turns Indigo and starts to Fizz even harder. Spit in it
The mixture turns mauve, it starts to fizz like crazy you manage to pitch the
Concoction out the window and duck under the cable just in time. It explodes with a tooth rattling bang.
All right fine. You find a scrap of paper in a drawer that looks like instructions for an elixir
But it's all in Goblin science Jargon. You don't understand it
Alright, whatever, let's go red lumps.
Uhh, Muave Slime? Green ooze!
Shake it? It turns violent and starts bubbling like crazy after a second though it settles down
All right, I'll keep it sure
I've got something. Hey, you want something?  Got something. Here's your elixir probably
The goblin moves away from the ladder and takes little sips from the flask savoring the flavor. Is it good? Yeah, perfect!
Okay, all right, whatever
That's that's not natural
All right, okay, holy crap if it isn't the most disturbing thing you've ever seen
I don't want to know what it is
Presumably a couple of goblins popping-ed it in here and the spores got all mixed together they seem reasonably chill about it though
Hey, uh, guys.  Those jelly beans can I to having them? Oh, what our fruit rocks, no!
No, not taking our fruit rocks these being ours not for you taking! Jeez louise
Well, what's your plan for dealing with this horror?
Talk to him not like looking like you're eating them a jar is still full what eating
Fruit rocks not for eating fruit rocks just for looking at. Just for looking at them
Not fitting through floor hole can't leaving room fruit rocks only entertainment being. Good grief, that's sad.
Okay, how about I teach you something else entertaining something better than fruit rocks looking at it. Okay? Sounded good. I agreeing
I'm not for certain, but what being better than fruit rocks oh by the way instead of intimidating I got
Hornswoggling, so when I want to convince someone of something to do something or other for that I want him to do I got to
give them the old
Hornswoggling
You know what I mean?
Poker. You pull out a spare deck of cards and pick a couple handfuls of cactus spines off the floor to use in poker chips
And give the goblins a quick poker playing tutorial. Plus, they have themselves rearranged so they can't see each other's cards
They take to it pretty quickly all right then can I have it
Nice, all right cool all right. See you guys. That was totally worth my time
And buy my time I mean completely replaying the game to become moxie specialist.
Oh, look, Granddad, okay?
We already got that so we got to go back to Jelly Bean Man. Roy Bean! Oh, also
I got to go to the forest of darkness, what?
I'm a reschedule it with my hornswoggling.
A duel, eh? How about we meet about high noon
About half hour, be back here tomorrow. Okay. See you buddy. See ya buddy pal. How you doing?
Hello, you want another one, okay?
God, I'm wonderful
All right looks like they're all here, too, goblins didn't eat any? It's a long and weird story. Well never mind then.
You've done a swell job kid, I've only got one more jar of Jelly beans missing it was stole by a gang of damn hippies
What'd they take him?
Heck if I know what hippies thinkin all I know is that they took off headed south and a little bit West
Go to Shroom Cave?
I do want to go to Shroom cave? I really want to go to Shroom cave.
Oh, nice. I've got a shroom picking thing. Is there gonna be any good around here wow?
Okay, there's a lot of shrooms in here..
Hey, what's that one?
That one's a spicy shroom. Can I get any of these? What did I buy those shroom pluckers for anyway?
Why is there so many goddamn shrooms in here?
Hello? Ah.
Mushroom map. I don't know what that is, but I got shroomgrow for Gary. So that's nice, give to Gary. Ah, deliciousness.
Good
It's a mushroom wrap
This map is labeled Shroom Locations and shows a weird
Convoluted trail leading to a big x. You recognize the x is this very cave the source of the trail looks like it's right near that
weird fort full of dirty weirdos
Okay, alright, then oh
Hello, this cultist is totally zonked out. The cultist
is muttering and twitching in his sleep. Mushroom Crumbs litter the floor around him. Loot his belongings.
Grab everything that isn't nailed to him. Skeleton bone, human ashes, burnt scroll all right well not that, this is what I wanted burnt scroll. Examine it.
The scroll is in bad shape and you can't really make out anything new but you're convinced this must be another clue as to whereabouts of
the necromancer. You stick the scroll in your journal. Alrighty then
Cool. Ley Lines
Cryptic note about Hellcow energy oh, I gotta find that
Again, that's the one thing that it didn't refind
But I'm pretty sure these guys are all from the fort of darkness
If I'm not mistaken the hippies are from the fort of darkness look at these damn hippies with their damn hippie signal
Ah hi, can you talk to me Gary ah?
Ah, soldier hearing. Except.. Yeah, the sitar music isn't very mirrored militaristic is it come on?
Let's have a look let's go in here. Why do they have all these canons have flowers stuck in the barrels?
Hey, what's going on here? Oh?
Hi, well, then sorry I interrupted. Hi, I'm Mumflr. teeth teeth Clavicle femur teeth
Wow ok alright?
You seen any Jellybeans? teeth Jaw Bone teeth. I see
Would you like some bones?
You hand her an armload of bones and she starts mechanically picking through them selecting some and discarding others based on Criteria
You can't discern
Eventually haven't chosen the best two from the pile she secures them together with a wire and
Screws and hands you something that basically looks like a sword
Great!
Deal Spooky Damage, how about some skull chips?
Oh, great. She stops muttering her eyes seem to focus a little she takes him glue out of her toolbox and presses the chips into a ring
Have more random encounters with Skeletons
Great. That's what I wanted. I don't have any gold teeth, so I'm just gonna leave you to that. Hi. I'm Mumflr
Salutations Mumflr they call me the talking dude because of my extensive knowledge of the principles of
Philosophy and the arguments and conundrums surrounding its various aspects of interpretations
I bet that's not why they call you that.   Can I interest you in a discussion of the particulars of curtsy and philosophy, Mumflr?
No.
Have you seen any jellybeans? Well first, we must take care to define our terms. What does it mean to see Jellybeans?
What if it was I
See as jellybeans are different than what you see. Cut the crap before I cut it for you. Ahem.
No, I have not but I do know that Irene the newest and dare
I say most delightful of our little clan
is particularly fond of them. You might ask her. Can I interest you in a discussion? Sure, but if you bore me.  The talking
Begins and you immediately tune out. Bla bla bla bla but from an epistemological standpoint
Bla bla bla
fascinating
Determinism. Narrow your eyes. Your posture alone is enough to keep him talking
That's interesting
oh
Good
Aha
whoa
Fascinating oh my yes, oh
It actually seems like some of this is rubbing off on you. Well shit. I got some mysticality!
interesting oh
Yes
My my sir, okay. Goodbye all right fine. Well that was weird
What the hell is happening here? I thought this was gonna be a cultist camp, but apparently not.
Oh man, I wish I had loco weed that'd be great. I don't have any binoculars for that one.
Hello
Hi are these for sale pretty cool boots he made, huh?
No, I mean, I'd like to sell them to you but they aren't mine. You didn't make him. It's funny
how everyone assumes but no these were all made by elves. God their eyes are really
really disturbing
Yeah, man like little elf guys. They're hard to see, out of the corner of your eye, you know?
But I was just kind of standing here and just kind of...... then I'm like oh
Hey, got another pair of boots in my hands guess the  elves made them more boots
Huh. I haven't made a pair of boots myself in I dunno, like a year? Years? Something. These elves keep making them though,
I don't know why weird. You seen any Jellybeans? Jellybeans weird
No
I haven't seen anything like that. Ask the elves maybe.
All right
you should open up a boot store a
store to sell your boots in. Their not  mine though, there.. Right, right, the elves'
But the elves can't be making them just for fun, right?
I'm I think they're making them so you can sell them. Ah yeah that makes sense
There's a town called Dirtwater you could open up a really nice shop there. All right cool
Hi, new face. My name is um one sec Irene
Great. Everyone here just calls me Mushrooms, so I forget sometimes. Howdy, Irene, I'm Mumflr. What's your story?
Oh, not much to tell! I was hitchhiking to Frisco a few months back, but I stopped here and never got around to continuing, you know?
We're like a big happy family here, and everyone's so nice and appreciative about how I know so much about mushrooms. Mushrooms?
Uh-Huh?
They're good for all kinds of things if you know which ones to pick if you want I can tell you some of my favorites
Okay
See any Jelly beans?
Oh yeah, I had some jellybeans recently you don't remember, huh? Oh, they were in my lounge. Where's your lounge? I don't remember
It's only there part of the time anyway. Yeah, I don't know
All right, I'll buy a mushroom. What the hell is that?
Opens your third eye halfway increasing your mysticality by 23 for the rest of the day
Goddamn I wish I was a bean slinger now no
I'm not gonna replay the game as a bean slinger although, that'd be pretty damn cool
Neat, thanks.
All right, gonna mosey on down this way see what else is in the rest of this camp. Hello. Hi
I'm Todd nice to meet you. I've been researching
Mushrooms. Okay. Like how they totally get you racked, hahaha I'm kidding they have interesting properties that could be a boon to medicine and a solution to psychological disorders
That's pretty interesting. The side effect they also get you absolutely smashed. It's just a happy side-effect. Yeah
If you have any Lactarius Dirtihippica... In fact, I do.
Fully Opens Your third eye
Go easy on this stuff. It has a real kick. Thanks sure okay. All right. Seen any jellybeans? Know anything about a lounge?
What are you doing? I'm making some dumb noises to entertain myself. Me too, man, me too.
That's pretty much what I do every day. Alright.
Do you know where Irene's lounge is? Yeah,
I do don't don't tell the talking dude if you don't mind, but it's in that cave where we get all mushrooms
I gotta be ah ah okay. I got-
*Disco Music*
Okay, all right gonna turn off music. This record must be from a foreign country where music is way weirder. Alright.
Can I exercise with you? You do not have the proper attire, before muscle come skin, before skin comes clothing.
You look around and sure enough everybody else is wearing the same striped pants and weird fuzzy headband
Don't I have a fuzzy headband? Do I?
Don't I. Yeah, I do. I actually do.
As far as striped pants goes.....
I don't know.
I don't know
Welp I need striped pants which I don't have so I'll get that later. Alright. See you guys.
Ooooo
Load it. Ooo. Nice. Artillery Saver? Holy shit. Safecracking.
Oh.
Army-issue sidearm.  Wow. That's actually damn good. That's damn good
Yeah, but is it any better? No? It's not better. It's not better. It's good, but it ain't better. Ooo. Military Cemetary
Plot 420. Great. Yeah, hilarious. Cannon Loading for idiots. Alright. What is that?
Read it. This book is so rudimentary that it's insulting to your intelligence even though you don't know almost nothing about loading cannons. Okay, alright.
Sounds good. Thank you for that. Alright. So I need to go back to that cave and open my third eye.
Don't know what that's gonna do for him. Scam him out of some meat?
Hotter gotta be hotter hot hot gotta cook cook it right through needs to be hot hotter hotter
Okay, alright.
Scam him out of some meat.
Having trouble with your cook stuff not hot enough?
I see I've got this little bag of spices. A couple pinches is inferno
Alright, okay.
Good. I hogswoggled  them real good. Alright. Here we go. Let's open up my third eye
Blammo. I got Bacharach Galactarious.
The world turns inside out as your mind replaces it.
Okay, the difference doesn't seem all that significant, but that's fine.
Woah.
I'm just gonna check to see if there's anything else other than that weird mystical open door in the middle of the goddamn place.
Alright. I'll go in the weird mystical door in the middle of the goddamn
Pretty nice lounge. Alright I got a strange lamp.
Jellybeans lime lime Jellybeans your great grandkids are gonna love this kind of music. Sure they are.
Well, then I found the lounge and my eyes open as shit, bro
Right I got I got your beans dude. I went on a journey to get these well
I'll be that word. I didn't figure on seeing any of them Jelly beans again and here you've brought back all three jars.
I ain't got much to reward you with other than a handshake, Mumflrm
but maybe I'll be able to pay you back somehow in the future.
Don't sweat it Roy, I was happy to help.
I'm a good guy. I'm a real good guy. So anyway, that's all the time I got for this episode.
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know in the comments how I'm doing and you'll see more shooty
Shooty bang bang in the next episode right soon. So thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video.
Bye-Bye!